wenn du nicht aufhörst bei erste gegen
mich zu hetzen müssen sie nie wieder
sehen das schwächt ja verpiss dich
endlich suche jetzt sagen sie mir schon
selber sagen hast du dich schon gefragt
willst du solle sich verpissen mal die
meisten von euch noch ein video auf dass
ich vor einiger zeit reagiert habe es
waren hierfür video und in diesem video
ging es darum dass ein junger mann seine
freundin sehr gern hatte und zwar so
gerne dass er sie gemästet hat das video
nicht gesehen wir sehen ja das ist
eigentlich erinnert also das ziel von
diesen menschen ist wirklich nur seine
freundin möglichst dicht zu machen
nein geld macht also eigentlich eine
ganz normale beziehungen und man kennt
das ja aus seinem persönlichen umfeld in
so einer beziehung er wird aber jetzt
immer einen partner der den anderen
möglichst fit machen will
von diesem wunderbaren pärchen ist heute
vor genau zweieinhalb stunden der zweite
teil eingegangen die durch hat sich
nicht entgehen lassen wir schauen oder
ein video zwei zentimeter mehr
ich habe dir doch gesagt ein bisschen
disziplin wille kriegen wir das klingt
kriegen wir es hin dass du wirst ja ich
bin so stolz auf dich unser feind ist
halt das habe ich dir noch was nicht
gemacht ganz kurz ohne wäre ich bin kurz
davor zu kurz der blick auf diesen tisch
kicker aber wie kann man sich selbst so
sehr auf dass man diese rolle haben
hinter die hat muss man so als junger
schauspieler ist wahr dass er sagte ja
klar das spiele ich das junge mädchen
was ich von ihrem freund messen lässt
nächsten leben weiter aus gelben karten
rechtzeitig zwei pizzen tief gesessen
werden natürlich das recht in der
tiefkühl sofaecke gelagert acht stück
alle nur 40 wirtschaftskrisen die nicht
gut schmecken sie auch noch gleich viel
besser
dass der ekelhaften so neidisch auf dich
zum perfekten körper ich bin so
glücklich mit ihr
[Musik]
so kommst du nämlich auch mal an die
frische luft und in meine ohne unser
plan zu zerstören in dem wagen verbrennt
nämlich keine einzige kalorien der
letzten folge hatte tatsächlich seiner
freundin verboten sich zu bewegen
hier sieht man wie sehr louis ashley
kontrolliert und manipuliert und ashley
lässt das aus liebe zu ihm mit sich
machen hoffentlich merkt sie bald dass
liebe eigentlich etwas anderes bedeutet
ich glaube das ist dummheit liebe geht
auch darum dass man sich am besten lässt
wie eine fackel und einem bollerwagen
durch die stadt gezogen
okay dass ich ihre beste freundin hat
meine letzten folge schon gesehen und ja
die ist auch eine ganz gefährliche route
weil bevor sie sich versieht wird sie
von unseren kollegen hier im zimmer
eingesperrt und einfach wie sonnen
stopfleber ganz einfach folge punkt wäre
vielleicht wieder schaffen dass ihr
bringt das gleiche gesagt oh mein gott
sie sprechen ja gleichzeitig bist du
eigentlich behindert salat in meiner
gruppe jeder kennt das man streichen
jeder erst mal klar ich habe auch mal
wieder gutmachen konnte also bei einer
flachen strecken nicht zur versöhnung
mit mit grünzeug ankommt ist er wurde
gut eine person nominieren
ich dachte ich dachte das ist mitunter
natürlich mit salatmischung fertiges
lassen im kopf ich natürlich gekoppelt
hergestellt ich habe gekocht kann macht
ist mein willst du mich muss genommen
weil da kann man keine vorhersage
treffen die anderen zum laufen gekommen
gleich viel freude das essen gibt mir
kraft ich bin wirklich ein menschliches
wesen ich brauche nahrung um zu
überleben
nein das ist los mit ihm und jetzt macht
er ist ein hobby für meine alte user
ganz okay ich dazu sagen dort war schon
durch getroffen
was blendet du es so und ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht so aus dass es
darüber traurig war das jetzt am haus
bürgermeister als du bist doch nur
neidisch weil du nicht mehr die nummer 1
ist
ich habe immer gut
der käse ist immer gut ich muss los mein
brav und enttäuscht mich nicht wir ist
ein weg ich bin zu erschließen ist ja
aber er steht will ich leider nicht
sehen also ab ist sich da wo du
hergekommen ist am besten in ein anderes
land oder einem kontinent dritte klasse
grundschule hoch
während es nicht kennen oder verpiss
dich du bist was gut ist weil da muss
ich erst muss ich da noch
das problem ist dann wieder dahin noch
nicht
mittlerweile wird es ganz kurz das war
zuvor die auch noch die alte bitten uns
einfach mal dabei und es ist nicht so
schwer da dieser gerade gemacht haben
ich glaube kennen gerade dass sie
relativ viele kalorien hat das grün
verfüttern könnte wesentlich weil
höchstem also alles was irgendwie ist
sie ihrer freude hin
die frist auf das beste gegen mich zu
hetzen
siehst du sie je wieder sehen das
schlechte ja verpiss dich endlich alter
sucht sie jetzt sagen dass mir schon
selber sagen hast du dich so stadtrat
praktisches wissen bisher noch eine
grundschule
[Gelächter]
wenn ich nicht das bekommen was ich
kriegen wir ja gar nicht ganz intim
werden
louis macht sich mit dieser aktion
erneut strafbar droht mira und versucht
sie dadurch von ashley fernzuhalten
wenn mir ihnen anzeigt erwartet ihnen
mindestens eine saftige geldstrafe
ich glaube dass keine nötigung der will
einfach nur mir an ashley verfüttern
kurz darauf
für st
[Musik]
was ist denn los
das freut mich nicht wenn die ganze
folge
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja ich bin der 3 es gibt eine wichtige
probleme aber weiß noch vor drei jahren
als wir an dem tempel durch gefunden
haben über den muss ich jetzt sofort
reden außerdem über die bürgerdienste
gibt da wird überhaupt übergehen wollte
ich dann versucht man noch ein dritter
weltkrieg er hier das bringen gespräch
egal das problem ist selbst wenn jetzt
heute kommt die türe auf kritik des
landes immer noch die lebt auch an der
tür sind monatelange harte arbeit von
ihrem bruder durch einfach wegschieben
[Musik]
ich kann nicht aufstehen und andorra
verrecken alter werden bringt wieder
feste nahrung machen da es wieder ab
diesem zeitpunkt passiert dann
eigentlich gar nicht mehr so viel tolles
die kriegen irgendwie hin diese heftig
zu retten sie trennt sich dann von dem
freund und alle leben also sieht ganz so
aus als würde in zukunft nicht mehr
gemustert werden
die könnte allerdings jetzt mal ein
youtube kann am besten indem er hier wo
ich verstand videoclip wirklich voran
schaut gerne weiter und und lass die
finger vom york